the voice season 11 mentors revealed  could you say team Adam Joan Jett Bette  Midler Sammy Hagar and Charlie puth have  all signed on to assist the coaches on  the hit NBC competition show this season  so who's paired with who you can always  do it your way I'm the prime example new  coach Miley Cyrus will be paired with  Joan I like that arrangement and shows  other new coach in addition Alicia Keys  will be paired with 24 year old Charlie  Blake Shelton is matched with Bette  Midler and Adam Levine will pair up with  Hagar's accomplished what we wanted to  accomplish The Voice returns on  September 19th on NBC but a special  preview episode will air on august  twenty-first following the closing  ceremony of the olympics